what's up freaks
I'm Greg I'm John we're gonna watch the
trailer for child's play Don Mancini
returning the original voice actor for
Chucky is back everyone's in good
spirits about it we all love our remakes
and reboots hey before we happen that I
wanted to say thank you to all ya mother
effing [ __ ] who are following us on
the Stardust app over there we do
30-second reaction R abuse that's the
time limit you got on it for films TV
shows and trailers some of them are even
micro sketches we post daily over there
it's free to download you like free [ __ ]
so to Y free to use so do it today
none of it costs money except for the
time and time is more valuable than
money so just consider it
[Music]
Vande what I did not realize Aubrey
Plaza
isn't it so uh yeah and Brian sorry
Henry oh cool
[Music]
[Applause]
cool
yeah that's much more of a teaser
excellent either way I like the dark
jingle behind it yeah tire time that was
really great
I love the updated cinematography I love
all the updated appeal this of it and
you know the first it's weird even
though it's something like a minute long
the first 20 or 30 seconds like okay
yeah just uh you know a sleeker glassy
look and remake of child's play and then
it started to go like really crazy
towards like they've made Chucky a lot
more high-tech and I wonder how that's
gonna play laser scanning on face skin
yeah like what the hell was that all
somebody's on close-up shots of just
like little tech bits I'm like what kind
of dollars yeah and I know that they've
set up a lot of stuff online about like
the caslen corporation like the
different products they sell and stuff
like that so there's a lot of like viral
marketing they're doing to in that smart
smart smart well I mean it looks like
it's gonna go big kind of seems I
slightly remember child's play too it
seems like it's gonna kind of feel semi
hybrid of both in a way cuz Travis
played gets bigger factory schoolers and
stuff whereas the first one's fairly
contained yeah you know yeah pretty much
at their housing you know other
apartment yeah yeah well I mean it seems
also like Andy's a bit older in this
movie to which I'm a little curious
about cuz at least as I recall re
watching the original child's play not
long ago you know he's a smaller child
and that's part of the terror it's like
how innocent he is and the proximity
between him and the doll so this kid
looks maybe a little bit more mature but
I don't know I feel like this is a movie
that once I revisited the original III
didn't love Chucky but then I watched it
again I was like wow this is actually a
pretty pretty damn scary yeah and this
looks menacing in a different way than
that movie but still pretty menacing you
know yeah it looks like from the
producers of it
[Laughter]
and I'm curious to see IRA Plaza in a
role like this because I'm used to her
playing that role she was like this that
I like but you know she's usually dry
you know kind of aloof witty leather
character I think Aubrey Plaza is a very
underrated actress if you've seen Ingrid
goes west I have not seen no she's
amazing in that crazy in that film I've
heard but but they even that even the
trailers I saw for that I was like okay
this feels more like a knob root Plaza
type of rollers her playing a mom here
I'm curious about just cuz that seems
like something that would have to be
more restrained in just a different kind
of performance I I haven't zeroed out
and her performance here I feel she's
gonna be fine I don't have a doubt about
I'm just saying like I am personally
excited to see a different dimension of
her acting abilities John gave her some
credit I do I like ivory plays hating on
Aubrey Plaza right now that's what I
ought to do stop famous I'm concerned
about Brian Tyree Henry oh yeah that guy
can't a guy can't act a ball never
showed any sense of skill or anything
like that is the one I'm most concerned
about and yeah because I I'm weirdly
looking forward to this now okay but is
are they keeping the Chucky franchise
alive and the other side of it because
it had the the the the movie that was
straight to DVD that people really liked
yeah people really like that I haven't
seen it yet but people really dug that
film and are they're doing a TV show
yeah Don Mancini and all the original
creators and stuff are doing the TV show
I think Brad Dourif is involved with
that but I'm not sure the movie
everyone's mad about because ostensibly
they are making this to hold on to the
Chucky rights I think there's a
breakdown basically of like I think
Mancini or somebody owns the rights the
first couple and then the studio and the
rights to the rest of them so they want
to keep him by making this movie at the
same time Mancini's making his show yeah
so there will be two Chucky's
concurrently running I think this even
drops the day the show premieres
so oh really yes
there's just gonna be two Chucky's now
okay the show's gonna continue like off
that movie it's gonna continue the
universe already set up by Don Mancini
in them and this is gonna be its own
thing well I can deal with that I mean
the thing for me is I I appreciate
child's play I've seen a handful of the
movies I don't adore the first one
enough that I'm not going that I'm gonna
like boycott this or something
I I'm intrigued because I like the cast
and I think that could be cool well I
think the upsetting factor with it is
the fact that Don Mancini is not back in
me this is Brad Dourif Brad Garrett yeah
break by Lowe's Raymond yeah what we
need in this movie is some
self-awareness and for when Chuck he's
alive and Andy realizes it for there to
be a Toy Story joke there needs to be a
Toy Story yeah he needs like write his
name on Chucky's foot because the last
time I saw shouts why I'm like wait a
minute a toy comes to life for this kid
named Andy that's Toy Story and this
needs to have some self-awareness how
you feel a sense of it feels like
there's some type of humor in this movie
even though this is like the serious
trailer I like there's little shots here
or there like when these like Asian guys
or something or like smoking a cigarette
then the body falls behind them and
friend that like little sequences like
that are things yeah it's probably a
slight humor to it throughout yeah or
the cop like wrapped up in Christmas
lights and stuff like that you know a
and with the whole kind of advanced tech
angle I got imagine you know they may be
playing a little broad and also humor is
not something foreign to the child's
play films no definitely not
well the first ones more serious tell me
yeah yeah and then they because like
every slasher franchise they just become
whack years they move on we don't know
who's playing Chucky in this one right
not to my knowledge I mean it's not on
IMDB okay so uh I'm not sure huh maybe
it will be Brad Garrett
maybe that's the awesome we recast
heavens Kevin
it's chucking these complete update I
was doing Johnson well scary yeah it was
clearly articulated Chuck you're right
there
well we talked for an awful long time
about at one minute trailer why we give
a patron the day shout-out to someone
thinking Derek Mitchell ah that makes
sense
you see Derek Mitchell used to be a lyft
or uber driver he would go around
killing people left and right and now
he's stopped now it works for an IT
company yeah and over there he's mass
producing these really adorable /
insanely creepy dolls that apparently
are cyborgs now mm-hmm oh yeah he's
equipped them with tons of advanced
futuristic features like face
recognition fingerprint recognition
that's very impressed the ability to get
inside your mind and gain your trust
well when he was a lyft or uber driver
he was murdering primarily children
mm-hmm so this is really intuitive you
know everyone has a job and everyone has
a passion and sometimes your job and
passion don't coexist
fortunately for Derek Mitchell he is now
able to make both his career and his
passion all in one dude by
mass-producing these dolls that can kill
children for the castling she's so happy
for you Derek good for you
thanks for being part of our patreon
page for so long I know December was
kind of a rough month but keep up the
murders free man because you know what
we don't get enough of those kind of
people out there yeah man plus there are
a lot of people around and there aren't
all that many resources guys you can
subscribe to the reject nation click
that notification bell and make sure to
download and follow us on the stardust
app peeps it's free to download free to
use I shop at Target buy